the most effective way that the left
amasses and wields political power
is by the control of language this
happens to be my upcoming
book speechless controlling words
controlling minds available now for
pre-order
they wield language as a weapon
to control the culture to control our
minds and control our politics and this
leaves us
with really really awful slogans you
know the sort of woke slogans that i'm
talking about well i'm here
to give you the definitive tier ranking
of
the woke slogans now here you know you
hear all these different tiers the a
and the b and the c and then there's the
s to your level so we've got
our own categories here at the bottom
level we have
the the sort of people who refer to
caitlyn jenner as a she
right this is the go along to get at
long level of the woke slogans
then the next level up we have the you
post crying videos on social media
why can't women have abortions okay you
are emotionally invested in this point
you're you're
really kind of into it then the second
highest level
that is at the you exclusively shop at
black and brown owned businesses level
you know i mean you are really
in it you are bought into this ideology
you're really willing to put your
your money where your mouth is and then
finally there's the top tier
that is the you took your kid to drag
queen story hour level right that is the
absolute
worst of the wokest of the wokest of the
worst before we begin this video
is brought to you by acre gold which we
will hear more about in just a minute
first
let's start up the slogans my body
my choice my body my choice
is probably the lowest level i mean it's
it's talking about this egregious thing
which is
killing babies to the tune of a million
babies a year in this country please
kill my baby but this is the basic level
because you'll hear this from people who
aren't even all that woke they'll say
variations on this like
you know a men shouldn't have an opinion
on abortion that's a women woman's issue
especially men like me who just have no
confidence or thoughts of my own so we
don't do that and from women you're
my body my choice but everybody says it
so that's that bottom level
you you're the sort of person who just
refers to caitlyn jenner
as a she another inversion okay next one
pay your fair share your fair share that
would be
gosh that would be another yeah i'm
afraid that's just referred to caitlyn
jenner as a she i know plenty of
moderate republicans people who you know
they'll vote for
mccain one day and obama the next day or
obama one day and romney the next day
they're kind of these moderate types
who go into this they'll say you know
the corporations need to pay their fair
share or the rich people need to pay
their fair share
and they haven't really thought about it
too much they're certainly not going to
post videos of themselves crying on
social media
but but they are espousing this sort of
frivolous line i mean what is your fair
share right i mean i
right now the rich people in this
country pay something like 97 percent of
income taxes so what's the is your fair
share 98
99 no it's just envy there's no there's
no limit to it it's just give me gimme
gimme
it's not even really about acquiring
anything right the people who call for
this
are not really getting a ton really that
money is just going
to government programs so we can ship it
overseas and have drag queen story hour
in syria or so i don't know i don't know
exactly what we're doing with the money
that one lowest tier next up
silence is violence okay now we're
moving up a little bit
so silence is violence is
is a confusing one because we're told
that for instance if you are a white
person
and you state your opinion in some way
that that
on a racial issue that that is violence
we're told that if you're a man
and you state your opinion on what is on
a sexual issue
that is violence we're told that if
you're a conservative at all
and you espouse any kind of conservative
you on a college campus
that is violence right we're told that
speech is violence
also silence silences violence so
pretty much anything you do or do not do
is
violence violence this you're getting a
little more
you know you you have definitely cried
on social media you
you have the videos up they're not maybe
it's not all the time
but they're they're there that would be
that would be the
next up tier okay what's next diver
diversity is our strength this is
oh this line oh my gosh this line
doesn't make any sense i mean just as a
matter of um
sort of basic philosophy unity is a
strength right
if we're talking about like the
transcendentals of being like unity
unity is good right things have
strength you know you're you're uh a
chain is only as strong as the weakest
link right you want things to be unified
you want them to have integrity
uh e pluribus unum out of many one
so many different types in america but
they all come together
a join or die this was the french and
indian war cartoon drawn by
benjamin franklin right coming together
in unity and then the libs come in and
they say no actually diversity is our
strength diversity is not
it's not our strength it's not a
strength at all and
this doesn't mean that we can't have
lots of different people in the united
states and all sorts of different types
but they actually have to lose some of
their identity in order
and they need to take on an american
identity and they need to
ditch some of the things that make them
separate and take on things
that will bring them into the american
hole you're not allowed to say that now
but this one is
without question the bottom tier this is
the sort of person who calls caitlyn
jenner
sheep fight for 15. so this one you got
to be a little more in the weeds
this is not the kind of diversity is our
strength beep boop
pay your fair share beep beep boop but
you know it's not it's not the sort of
thing that has just been so drilled into
us all the time that we do you have to
be paying attention to
left-wing news outlets to even know what
fight for 15 is it's this idea that
we need a 15 minimum wage or something
uh
this you're you're at least posting
crying videos on social media
you may well only shop at black and i'm
actually going to bump this one up this
is going to be
you only shop at black and brown owned
businesses because you're you're
pretty in the weeds especially on labor
issues
and you're you know you know the slogans
that probably are not going to become
super popular
for another you know five or six years
so that that's good that one's actually
pretty high up there
next follow the science you dumb sheep
give me your mask so i give them to my
friends no now you gotta wear your masks
you dumb sheep
hey fetchy you're attacking science
follow the science
yeah that's the bottom tier called bruce
jenner she
it's really distressing how many of
these slogans
are at that bottom tier because it's not
that the slogans aren't radical the idea
that we follow the science like we make
a god out of
the science whatever the science is that
we we
do not understand that all human
conflict is ultimately religious
we do not recognize that there is such a
thing as philosophy such a thing as
ethics such a thing as
morality we just it's all just
disorients you know and it's like
it's that meme where it's like the
letters are lowercase and capitalized
alternately
it's so it's one of the dumbest
expressions out there
and yet it's a radical expression too
because it's so
wickedly materialist um but it's very
popular it's the bottom one you call
bruce jenner
is she next up black lives matter yeah
another just
tote well no i'm i'm
this is this is the bottom tier this is
still the bottom tier i think
no no i'm gonna i'm gonna alter that
this was the bottom tier
everyone was saying this everyone was
posting the stupid black square on blm
day or whatever you know that everyone
was doing it
but i think that has changed there was a
time when even republican politicians
would say i believe black lives matter
and you're like oh bro you know
it's a marxist organization organization
that seeks to disrupt the western
prescribed nuclear family their words
not mine
they talk about the cisgender patriarchy
reads ridiculously
radical organization but all the all the
conservatives who didn't want to be
called racist
would go along and say well i believe
black lives matter seriously that i
think has stopped though i think
recently you don't really see that i
think blm has been exposed
for one it's been redefined as by large
mansions ever since the head of blm
was caught spending millions of dollars
on giant mansions
i think people now know that it's a it's
a racket people know it's
an extortion group and also after blm
burned the country down for about six
months i think
that's soured people on it so this one
you're gonna have to be a little higher
this
is you post crime videos on social media
here's something new really new the
price of gold
has been all over the place right there
is a way to buy gold
through a company called acre that will
allow you to subscribe to gold bars for
as little as
30 a month michael don't lie to me you
say i'm not i'm not i wouldn't lie to
you why do you because michael
gold costs more than 30 yeah i know it
does i know but with acre you get to pay
each month
once your gold stash reaches the price
of their gold bars they will discreetly
ship
acre gold to your house just recently
acre introduced a new 100 a month
subscription to a 5 gram gold bar i love
acre
i have acre gold physical acre gold not
on me right now i don't want to get
shaken down you know walking down the
street but i've got acre gold i really
really like it i've enjoyed investing in
precious metals especially when
inflation
is a concern which is absolutely true
right now especially
when the economy might be looking a
little kooky i find precious metals
great way to hedge your investments
visit getacregold.com start investing in
physical gold today make sure you go to
that url because acre is giving away a
gold bar to qualify for the giveaway
tweet or post why you should be the
recipient and mention at get underscore
acre
that is getacregle.com thank you aker
gold for supporting the show
next up that's not who we are okay this
one's a little higher
this is like for instance when we would
uh
use enhanced interrogation techniques on
terrorists
this is not quite what you'd call
torture but
it's you know a little tough it's a
little rougher and
some squishes made a big deal about this
and i said you can we can't
we can't torture the jihadis that would
be wrong
that's not who we are it's well
we're not we're not jihadis so yeah
they're not who oh the torturers
okay so they're saying basically the
jihadis would do that or some other
regimes would do that but we don't do
that why because we're not serious about
winning wars is that the point
that's not who we are at the geneva
convention says you can
i don't care if this thing's against the
geneva conventions i want it the geneva
convention
is designed to protect civilians in war
and it provides certain
accommodations to legal combatants in
war if you're a terrorist by definition
you are not adhering to the geneva
convention you're targeting civilians
for instance
so you're not entitled to those
protections and if you were given those
protections you completely undermine the
geneva convention so
i got off on a tangent that phrase
that's not who we
are it's a very silly one and it usually
just
means that's not who i want us to be
uh however okay this one is going to be
a little higher it's this is not just
the total basic level
this is you you do post crying videos on
social media you're probably crying when
you use
that stupid slogan next defund the
police yeah okay now we're bumping up a
little higher here i mean this is
you do not shop at a white-owned
restaurant or shop like no way i mean
this is
you are if you're doing defund the
police you
i think that most of your shopping is
done at night with rocks through windows
i'm a brick you know wearing masks and
not for covid okay
that that's a little more radical that
has not been totally mainstreamed i mean
you hear it with politicians
too but even even the squad types had to
back off of this a little bit and they
they are by far the most extreme on it
that's going to be that second highest
tier next up
love is love love is love okay
love that which is a a truism
i guess but it's not even it doesn't
convey anything right there are
different
kinds of love i love my wife
i love my son and i love my producer
i love them in very different ways if i
were to
confuse the way that i love them at some
point i
would very likely be committing a crime
there are different kinds of love
um but this insistence that we conflate
all sorts of love and just make it all
about sex or something is
creepy and gross and very stupid however
a lot of people say this a lot of people
i would say this is not the basic
well huh is it no i guess it is i guess
this has been so it's
it's been very mainstreamed even now i
mean this was a line used to
justify the radical redefinition of
marriage from what it had always meant
everywhere in human history
to this new radical redefinition that
takes sexual difference out of it
but even many republicans go along with
that now obviously anthony kennedy
the romantic poet of the supreme court
waxed poetic about this
so i think this is the lowest tier
you're the sort of person who calls
bruce
she no justice no peace
this is a little higher than the caitlyn
jenner thing this is
definite well this is higher than the
crying videos even because
you're not crying you're not coming from
a position of weakness no justice no
peace
usually when you say that you've got a
molotov cocktail in your hand or
something
like it during during the mostly
peaceful protests protests of 2020
when blm was terrorizing city after city
after city
you heard a lot of no justice no peace i
mean that is an explicit call for
violence the whole world must learn of
our peaceful ways
by force usually of the terroristic
variety right usually targeting
civilians
so that's going to be you you don't shop
at whitey's shop okay you
you are exclusive you are discriminating
against people definitely on their race
in your economic life that's going to be
the second highest tier
i can't breathe so i can't breathe is
this
this uh it's one of the slogans of blm
blm
has a lot of fraudulent slogans
so hands up don't shoot was the big one
with with michael brown
the the narrative was that michael brown
was a gentle giant who was gunned down
by a vicious cop and killed execution
style
while he was on his knees and his hands
up and he said hands up don't shoot and
none of that was true he had just robbed
a store
he was costing this cop he reached for
the cops gun
and finally the cop had to had to shoot
him and this was
affirmed by multiple autopsies and grand
jury and eyewitnesses and it's just
there's no basis to it so the slightly
more credible one was from the death of
george floyd where george floyd
said i can't breathe i can't breathe and
it was ostensibly because the officer
derek shoving was kneeling on his neck
however george floyd was saying i can't
breathe i can't breathe
video later revealed before he was on
the ground he actually asked to be taken
out of the cop car which is why he was
put on the ground
and so that the narrative kind of fell
apart however however
while this might not be the most basic
level it might not just be the bruce
jenner
calling you know calling him a she this
is only the next highest level this is
only you know you've posted the
occasional crying video on social media
and the reason for that is the truth of
these incidents the true complexities of
them
just don't get out because the media
powers that be
refused to permit this kind of stuff out
so this is going to be
the crying videos love not hate the
activist said
as he set fire to the courthouse it's
bringing love don't let it get away
break his legs love not hate the mostly
peaceful protesters said as he was
walking out with a pair of nike sneakers
from the shattered storefront love not
hate
screamed the blue-haired antifa activist
at the elderly trump supporter yes
another talk about conveying the
opposite of what it means but this is
this is a basic one this is
totally if you call bruce she
you for sure have said love not hate
earnestly not not ironically
eat the rich okay this one's a little
higher you actually don't hear this one
as much anymore
because this eat the rich goes back to a
classical marxism
that viewed the world in primarily
economic terms and viewed
social struggle as a matter of class
whereas the the cultural or neo or
western marxists they're called all
sorts of things
realized that the class thing wasn't as
effective but race
and sex and that those sorts of
identities are actually more effective
in creating a sense of solidarity
so it's really like the bernie types i
mean you've got to be pretty
you've got to be pretty into this it
resists
all of this classification because all
of these
the drag queen thing and the black and
brown businesses and the social media
and caitlyn jenner
they're all cultural matters and this is
just an economic matter but if i had to
just throw a dart at a dartboard and
pick one i would say
it's high enough up it's probably at the
shopping at black and brown businesses
only in as much as
you are making economic decisions now
you're making
public decisions based on your radical
ideology
michael knowles is literally hitler
so this is not the most basic level
this is because some i guess some people
just haven't heard of my show i don't
know why not probably because they
haven't read my upcoming book
but this is not the highest tier
this is not the you know the elite of
the elite you know like you're actually
taking your kids to drag queen story
hour
this is i don't even think this is you
exclusively shopped
at black and brown owned businesses i am
cold literally hitler
i think multiple times a day i mean this
is not it's not that
out there folks and i want you to know i
am not
literally hitler okay if any i think i
would be closer to mussolini wouldn't i
the kuruma the ducha you know the
italian
i'm not i can't even i don't even speak
german
nine nine free the nipple that is the
worst picture you possible that's so
gross
free the nipple is it's not the caitlyn
jenner she thing
it is some teenage boys who are who know
a good opportunity when they see one
it might be it's beyond even the posting
the crying videos it's more it's more
thought out than that
it's you're probably only shopping at
black and brown businesses i mean you're
you're really kind of down the rabbit
hole
at that point freeing the nipple why of
all the
why have all the pictures what what are
we to end on a bad note do we have any
more
oh that's so gross i gotta end with that
image of my i gotta end with the free
the nipple image come on guys
guys don't do this to me that's it
we have not made it to the s tier you
are not
there is we have not yet seen a slogan
that is only of the most
woke of the woke of the woke and do you
know why it's not because those slogans
aren't radical
they're very radical slogans it's
because the left has been so effective
at popularizing insanely radical stuff
that none of it i bet you could look at
every woke slogan out there
none of it is going to be only reserved
for the elite of the elite of the
because
they've popularized it they have
controlled our words
they are controlling our minds they've
left a speechless
a great book that you can pre-order
makes a great father's day present if
you like this video and you want to see
more like it be sure to comment below
what you want me to rank or react to
next we'll see you next time